in this video we'll talk about
streptococcus biogenes this is a high
yield video for USMLE step one
streptococcus pyogenes belongs to the
genus streptococcus and it's a group a
pathogen according to the land Fields
classification system
now streptococcus is responsible for
strep throat
in a free living bacterial Kingdom you
can see gram-positive and gram negative
bacteria based on gram staining
classification under the grams positive
bacteria there are cocci and there are
bacilli cocci are actually round and
ball like shaped organisms whereas
basically are Rod shaped among the cocci
there are several subtypes and
streptococci belongs to one of them
streptococci means there are a kind of
like a lineup of small sphere like
structures that can be clearly visible
under the microscope so you can see a
chain of these balls under the
microscope and they stain uh positive
for Gram stain so they are Violet in
color
streptococcus pyogenes is one of the
most frequently encountered bacterial
pathogen worldwide and there are several
virulence factor in this bacteria which
lead to all the complications I'm going
to break down all of these virulence
factor and how they can affect our body
in subsequent slides
so first of all let's talk about the
mode of transmission
so first these particular bacteria can
be generally infecting our body via the
nasopharyngeal root and especially it
affects the pharyngeal membrane so the
the cells under the pharynx they are the
one which gets affected and this lead to
streptococcal pharyngitis or simply
known as strep throat
so the transmission occurs via
respiratory droplets or skin contact
from an in fact infected person
now let me tell you that these bacteria
survives best in the human mucosal
membrane
so in the environment they don't stay
very well so that's why they get
transmitted from one human to another
that's what make them infective
so let's talk about the clinical
presentation there are different degrees
of clinical presentation so one of the
most common is strep throat
that means you have a sore throat fever
tonsillitis and then some kind of like
in extreme cases there could be
lymphatinopathy near your neck region
there is also mpdgo that means there is
honey colored crusts and small vesicles
around the mouth area
there is scarlet fever which which
includes arithmetics rash strawberry
tongue and sandpaper like rashes to be
very specific now this particular
bacteria can actually go to the systemic
circulation and lead to many other
complications for example fascitis
cellulitis that means acute inflammation
of the subcutaneous tissue and in
extreme cases myonicrosis that means
depth of the muscle cells
now let's talk about the structure of
the bacteria to appreciate its function
and its pathogenicity so this is how
overall streptococcus look like we are
looking at one unit of that
streptococcus strip so here you can see
it's kind of like a round shaped
bacteria with a capsule on the external
most site then there is cell walls
plasma membrane and most importantly
there is a protein known as M protein
which is important for virulence there
are lipoteloic acid and invasions are
very common in these bacteria invasions
like strepto lysines streptokinases
proteases are responsible for the
pathogenicity also exotoxins are key
aspect of understanding the pathology of
streptococcus pyogenes
so let's talk about the cell wall first
cell wall contains number of clinically
important components and then the most
important thing is fimbria so fimbria is
embedded into the cell wall it has M
protein and the n-terminal variable
region so
streptococcus pyogenes is actually
surrounded by a wide number of this kind
of fimbria so it's kind of like a fringe
of fimbria the fembria contains s
protein which is a virulence factor and
the M protein which is another one
so M protein is highly variable
especially in the n-terminal region
shown here and that's that leads to
different kind of
antigenic response for these bacteria
so let's talk about other stuff on the
membrane so there is group a specific C
carbohydrate and it is composed of
a complex polysaccharide
which is uh ramnossand in acetyl
glucosamine
all group a streptococci are by
definition contains this particular
antigen remember the classification that
we talked about in the beginning of the
video
then we talk about the protein F or
fibro nectin binding protein it allows
the attachment of the bacteria to a
membrane for example the pharyngeal
epithelial membrane
so that is why pharyngitis is very
common in case of this particular
bacterial infection let's talk about all
the toxins
first we'll talk about the pyrogenic
exotoxin this leads to this leads or
promotes nuclear neutrophil to
degranulate and it can cause various
effects including rash as seen in
scarlet fever and streptococcal toxic
shock syndrome is also associated with
this
then there is streptolysin O and
streptolysin S
both of these damage mammalian cell and
it result in lysis of the lysosomal
enzymes and allow its release so one of
the cell type that is affected by these
enzymes these toxins are neutrophils
then there is streptokinase that kind of
catalyze the conversion of plasminogen
to plasmin this got this leads to the
lysis of clots and facilitate the rapid
spread of these organism
also it blocks the complement system by
blocking the C5 a peptidase so basically
the complement system is broken down so
bacteria can evade the first line of
defense also it has higher loony days
which can break the hyaluronic acid
chains thereby it can remodel the
extracellular space
and it would allow the rapid spread of
these organism then there is a
strip to dnas so these dnases are
degrade the various part of the
genome so basically
it allows basically the rapid spread of
the bacteria inside the host body
the complications include rheumatic
fever
which is basically a similar to an
autoimmune condition with severe joint
pain
and then there is a post-treptococcal
glomerulonephritis all these
complications are not found in every
patient but this is also case specific
patient specific
so which lead to uh
nephritis and overall kidney related
problems
as this is a bacterial infection it can
be treated with antibiotics choice of
antibiotics include penicillin and
Amoxicillin if the person is allergic to
penicillin then there are other
antibiotics which can be possibly used
so
then uh basically
other treatment option includes
replenishing the body fluid and
electrolyte sometimes IV drip of the
fluids can be used useful as well
okay get notes and flashcards in our
Facebook page and Instagram links are
provided in the description you can
support our Channel using PayPal paytm
or UPI see you in next video
remember